よろしくお願いします
ねひぱーぱんかたんかまんさっじゅきらんわむっちゃてぃ
だはんたんばーらまんべーてぃ
ばすまっちゃんぬうぇぱーわく
ねひぱーぱんかたんかまんさっじゅきらんわむっちゃてぃ
だはんたんばーらまんべーてぃ
ばすまっちゃんぬうぇぱーわく
というあの偈文になり
偈になります  あの ねひぱーぱんかたんかまんというセクションには
ぱーぱんかまんというのは悪業ですね
かたんというのは犯した
で 犯した悪業は ねひっていうのは決してありませんということで
さっじゅきらんわむっちゃてぃ
さっじゅっていうのは瞬間
早くっていうことで で
きらんというのは牛乳のことで
むっちゃてぃというのは結果出すっていうことですね
いわゆる熟する 実るという意味ですね
それで あの 牛乳と同じくすぐ
あの 熟するというか 牛乳の場合は固めることですね
ずいぶん簡単にそんな早くはないんだよと
あの 悪業したら結果が出るのは
悪業の場合はその報い
結果が出るということで
むっちゃてぃは言葉正しいですけど
牛乳の場合はあまり合わないんですけど
一応二つにも同じ動詞使ってます
ではどういう意味かというと
牛乳 乳搾りをする それでそのまま置いておいてもどうったことはないんです
で 牛から牛乳を取っただけで
それは何かになるっていうわけじゃないんです
しかし 牛乳をそのまま飲むよりは
いろんな料理に作ったり食べたりするのはね
昔からあの 人間のね 習慣でしたから
あの インド文化ではものすごい牛乳使ったりはします
だから牛乳の で作る食べ物っていうのは大量にたくさんなります
それまたそんなに難しくはないんですね
作るのは 牛乳をとっていろんなものを組み合わせると
すぐ固まって そのまま固めてヨーグルトのようなものになっちゃうし
あるいはそのままそれはチーズみたいなものに入れ替えることもできるし
いろいろできますよ また
牛乳の硬いところだけ取り除いて
この液体のところ 例えば牛乳を固めていくと水が別になっちゃう
水と言ってもそちらものすごいいろんな成分が入ってます
で それだけ別にして それは飲み物にしたり
またそれに何かいろんなものを入れて
いろいろスープみたいな飲み物にしたりもする
それから牛乳の脂だけ別にとって
脂別りに作ったりもする
西洋的にはバターとチーズと
他何かありますかね ヨーグルトと
それしかないかもしれませんだけど
インド文化ではいろいろあります
まあそれは関係ないんですけど
一応 牛乳を乳搾りしただけですぐ結果出る
すぐヨーグルトが出るということはないんです
それには何か調合するものは必要なんですね
そのように何か悪業を犯した
すぐ瞬時に はい結果だよ
はい報いだよということは
そんなことはないんだよと
悪業にも実るためにちょこっと条件をそろえなくちゃいけない
条件そろった瞬間で 悪業の結果が出てきます
それで悪業っていうのはダハンタンバーランアンウェーティ
バーラン この愚か者をダハンタン
燃やしながら燃えながら燃やす
何て言ったら もう焼きつつね
燃えますからね 悪業したんだから精神的に
そうやって燃やしながらアンウェーティ
追っかけていくんですね
で 愚か者 罪を犯した人と一緒に悪業はいつでも一緒に来るんです
一緒に来て いつでも自分を悩ませて
精神的に燃やしたりはします
どのようなものかというと
バスマッチャンノーパパコー
火の玉は灰の中に隠れちゃうと全然消えませんね
よく持ちます 炭でもね
火を付けてからもう灰の中に入れておいちゃうと
ずっとその火がそのまま残っているんですね
普通っていうのはすぐ消えるはずなんですけど
1日2日3日でも灰の中だったら
その火はそのまま残っているんです
そのようにこの灰の中に隠れている炭火のように悪業したら
それは心の中で結果は出さないで待ってますよと
ちょっと条件そろったら結果は出しますよ
それで世の中の人々は悪いことをするのはものすごく好きで
良いことだったらなかなかやらないし
やりなさいと言ったらすごく腹が立って怒るんですね
だからこの人間っていうのはものすごい悪いことは好き
それってどういうことかというと
やっぱりすぐ即すぐさま結果が出てこないんですね
だからその時 このやるのは好きだから
やってる分は気分がいいんです
そういうことだから 簡単に悪を犯してしまうんです
悪を犯すことは随分気分が良くて刺激的でということで
だから四六時中悪をばっかり犯していて
それからじわじわと結果が出始めます
その 手遅れでもうどうすることもできないんです
例えば ものすごく怒りの妄想ばっかりやっている
で 欲はあることで妄想すると言ったって
もうほとんど人間ね  95%ぐらいはもう怒りの妄想しかやらないんですね
妄想し方といろんなことあるでしょうね
芸術に関わることを考えたりとか
いろんなことを考えることできるでしょうね
で 現代社会でも科学的に何が発明していますか
発見しているんでしょうかとか
で そういうものを面白おかしくいくらでも考えられますけど
そういうことは妄想しません
とにかく自我が強くて
怒りの妄想だけど この怒りということさえも分かってないんですね
だからそこはすごい複雑にしてしまって
で 心理学的にいろんなラベルを貼ったりして
これはこういうこと これはこういうこととかね
もう何千ぐらいでももう病気に症状名前つけてますけど
そんなたくさん要りません
ほとんど一つ  二つで終わりますからね
怒りの妄想か欲の妄想か
欲の妄想っていうのは面白いことで
人間っていうのはもう欲があるのはごくごく自然なんですけど
怒りよりは 遠い昔はもうお釈迦様でもこれ欲はなかなか断ちにくいんですねとか
タチが悪いねとか言ってるのに
現代社会を見るともうそんな余裕がないんです
もう燃えることにはもう精一杯なんで
自分で焼身自殺するのに
で ことには精一杯 だから例えば欲中心だったら
ものすごく派手で笑ったり遊んだり
面白く生きてるはずなんです
明るくて元気で 欲っていうのは悪いんだけど
人はそれなりに明るくはするんですよ
もう最低おしゃれぐらいでもします
美しく見せてやろうではないかと
かっこよく だからそういう何もことは服装はだらしないわ
髪型は見る気持ち悪いわ
もう体の調子が悪いわ
声がもう聞いていられない
もうもしかするとこういう鉄筋できた建物だから
このもうしびれてしびれてね
もう錆びてるかもしれない
中から 人間の明るい声っていうのはすごい立派なものですよ
この植物周り ものすごく声で元気になります
だから私たちはこの森みたいな生活していますから
森の中みたいに このどこを見てもココナッツという植物がありまして
人間が喋っているところだったら
もう一年中木はいっぱい実ってます
人の声はもうあまり聞こえないところで
それなりにあるだけで
一つの房なんとか言うんですか
そこでもう重いでしょうに
ココナッツは これ二十とか三十とか出ますよ
まあもう大人にはなんとかもう背中で運べるんです
かなり重いんです そんなものは三つ四つ実りますからね
ですから この それはやっぱり人間の声
あまり肥料を入れなくてもね
だから子供たちとかよく遊んでいるところだったら
もう別に木は実るんですね
だからこの それはまあふざけて喜んで遊んでいるんで
それ怒りに苦しみの声だったらね
そうはなりません それはとにかくまあ人間っていうのはもうずっとこのもう自分のことを悲観的に思うことやら
他人のことを悲観的に思うことやらね
その時はすごい刺激的ですね
あれが悪か 悪かった これが悪かった
あの人が悪かったとかね
あの人のあの態度は悪いんでしょうと
あの人あの言葉が悪いでしょうとかね
だから仕事に行ったっても
自分の収入を得るために仕事に行くのに仕事に悪口を言うんですね
こんな仕事をしたって意味があるのかとかね
もう嫌で仕事辞めたいと思ってるんだよとかね
だからどこまで暗いかというね
すごい不思議ですけど
私にとってはね なぜかというと
私だったらそれぐらい暗い思考だったらもう30分も持てません
体がこう倒れます これ一生頑張ってますから
結構忍耐力ありますねというか
それも業ですよ だから体壊してくれない
早く 80年間も燃やし続けるんだから
これ悪い 気持ち悪い もう体おかしくなるんだよとすぐ分かったらすぐ辞めます
そういうことで ではなんでそういうことをやっているのかで
その時は気分がいいんですね
人の悪口とか 人のことを悲観的にネガティブ的にごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ妄想したりすること自体は
まあ何のこともないと思ってるんですけど
自分が精神的にどんどんどんどんもうもう治り難い方向へ不治の病気になっていることは気づかないんですね
それで全体的に体が壊れちゃって
脳細胞はもう復活できん
だから人生一つまるっきり無駄にするんです
何のために人間に生まれたのか
それだったら犬で猫で生まれた方が良かったでしょうに
何とかして早く死んじゃいますからね
人間で生まれて それが台無しにするという
そういうわけで もうもう不善
不善思考の中でも やっぱり欲の思考はマシですよ
欲っていうのは まあ創造的で生産的で
破壊的じゃないんです
怒りは破壊的なんですね
欲も怒りも不善だから
もう結局は人はそれでどんどん堕落してダメになりますけど
その 2つを比較すると
もう初めから破壊的っていうのは何のこともないんだからね
そういうことで この精神的にも病気ということになってからは
もうどうしようもないんですよ
もう 誰にも助けてあげることはできないんです
もう壊れちゃったんで
人生は だから精神的な健康な時でさえ
自分の嫌な恐ろしい思考を止めることをしなかった
止められなかった人があの刺激のもうもう引っ張られて
それで病気になったらどうやって止めますかね
悪思考を止めるためにはかなり力が必要です
力があった時も止めることはできなかった人が
力が全部なくなった時
何とかしてくれと言ったって意味がないでしょう
今もう遅いということなんです
だから この一番罪の中で大きいのは思考ですよ
だから悪思考っていうのは出たらすぐそのたちまち切らなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし この問題は これがやりやすい
悪い思考はやりやすいんです
人と仲良くするよりは
喧嘩することはやりやすいんです
人のことを優しく考えるよりは
批判的に考えることはやりやすいんです
人の良いことを思う 思う思う出すよりは思い出すよりは
その人の悪いこと 欠点を思い出すことをやりやすいんです
世界もそうなってます
とにかくもうマスコミの世界というと
もうそのために人の悪口を
ための目的でも かなり世界的に有名なタブロイドといういろんな種類の英語で一応タブロイドというんですけど
新聞までできているでしょうね
イギリスだったらデイリーミラーでしたっけね
噂のことしか載らないという
でも随分もう格好あるもう立場のある新聞だそうです
だからこの そこまで人々はね
これ開発するんですね
人の悪口を探すということ
それでその技術も開発するんです
だからデータがなくてもほんとのごとく書ける
この文章の技術 結構もう開発しています
それは別に教えてあげたりする
ジャーナリズムと言って
いかに法律に立ち触れないように嘘を書けるのかという創作して作って
だから世界っていうのは
まあそういうところまで参っていって
まあ欲の世界にも まあないわけもないんですけど
やっぱり欲の世界よりは人の噂の方が売れるんですね
なんとかタレントさんがこんな服で来ていましたとかね
これはこれであれとかね
まあその説明よりは まあその人は裏で誰かと喋っていましたとかね
それもしかすると何とかあるぞとか
その方が ちょっとカメラの方ではなくて別な方を見てちょこっと手を振ったら
それで十分ですよ もう 2 3週間もう記事書くんです
それだけのデータで十分です
たり もしかするとあの人ではもしかしてこの人ではないか
Aさんではないかとかね
名前まで A さん  B さんとか言ったりして
それで事務所に調べたところで全くノーコメントでしたとかね
それだから法律に捕まらないでしょうね
事務所はもう頑固と断ります
そんなことはまるっきりありえないんだよとか言いましたよと
平然で書くんですよ それで読むバカどもたちは
やっぱりもう何がやっぱりですかね
いかにだらしないかというと
だから全くそういうことはもうないんだよと
あの子はもういつでも誰にでも手を振るんだよと言ったら
こういう風に言うんだよ
事務所はと だからもう各ジャーナリストの目的はいかに全く証拠なくても書けるかという
この技術は 全然見事なもんじゃないんですよ
あんまりにも気持ち悪いんですよ
見事ではなくて いかにこの読者が
脳細胞死んでるのかって
そこは私気持ち悪いんです
人間でしょうと なんでそこまでね
論理性がなくなっているのかと
だから昔 昔ではなく前のダイアナ妃がね
もう殺すまで追っかけていたでしょうに
それで死んでしまったところで
それがイギリス女王がやったことにしなくちゃいけないんですね
見事にストーリー作るんです
出て行った人はイギリス皇室にとっては何の関係もないんです
そちらはもう皇室だから
もう個人的に子供がいるんだから
もしかすると連絡したりすることできるかもしれませんけど
さっちり今さえできないんです
なのに もうそれはもうイギリスにはこういうシステムなんだ
そういうシステムありますよ
いろいろ もうFBIみたいなものはイギリスの方がもっとできたりものあることあるんですけど
まあこれいうこともあります
こういうこともありますとか言いながら
なんとなく読者にはやっぱりこれはもうバッキンガム宮殿から何かからくりあったでしょうと思わせるようにやったりするって
どこまでこの人々はね
もう他人の悪口ばっかり探して探して
この憎しみの思考で この刺激で生きようとしているのかと
だからそこでほとんど人間というのは精神的に病気になっていかれてしまいますね
慈しみとか優しさとか
人のことを心配するとか
仲良くしましょうとか
微塵もないので だから世界の思考の流れっていうのはね
一般的に見るともう信じられないほど変な方向には行っているんですね
だからそういう そういう社会で育てる人々にとっても
もうどうすることもできない
よっぽど人格ないと このシステムに汚染されないようにいることはできますけど
でもみんな流行に乗らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
あれ取り返しつかないほど社会の思考が壊れているんです
今は反対意見出したらもう居ぬきがないところまで行ってますからね
だからこの すぐ結果出るならばね
誰も悪いことをしないんですね
結果っていうのは この灰の中に隠れ蓑のように待っていて
それで攻撃するんです
攻撃し始めたら もう手遅れ
どうすることもできんです
だから一番弱い 一番弱いじゃなくて
何か弱い時を狙って結果が出ますから
悪い結果が だから初めから理屈理性がない生命でしょうし
それは危ないことというのはなおさら悪くなるんですね
例えば不幸になったとする
不幸になったら どうせ条件が悪い時に限って不幸がドーンと落ちてくるんです
それから次から次へ次から次へと崩れていくんです
で 本人はなんでこうなるんですか？なんでそうなる？私はそんな悪いことをやってないのにとかね
今更そんなこと言ってもね
意味がないんですよ 例えば体が病気になったとしてしまうと
そこは修理すると また別なところ壊れて
そこをなんとなくまた別なところ壊れていってて
それで体が壊れるだけじゃなくて
財産もなくなったりして
その家に帰るとまた離婚されたりしたりして
どこまでかとわからなくなっちゃうんです
そういうふうなことで
一旦崩れたらどこまででも崩れて崩れてはいく
それはものすごい力ありますよ
もう悪業しかやってないんだから
そことでも火の玉で十分ですよ
山火事になるために 条件は揃っている
そんなことで まあそんなにね
難しい教典というわけでもありませんけどね
まあそこで理解してほしいということは
この人間っていうのは基本的に心が汚れてますから
貪瞋痴というね 欲と怒りと無知というね
3つで汚れてるんだから
何を見ても判断してみる
判断する場合は 貪瞋痴という 3つの尺度で判断する
それが本能ですね だから欲張るのは簡単
怒るのはね 昔の人間だったらたまたま
だから一旦怒りだしたら
いくら素晴らしい条件であっても怒るんです
昔の人々はものすごい厳しく生活していたんだから
あの生きることで大変体力使って頑張ってるんだから
あんまり心汚れませんね
手で田んぼを作るんだから
余計なことを考える余裕がないんですよ
もう 自然の中で 一人田んぼをやっていたっても
周り鳥たちやら色んな動物たちが寄ってくるし
そこでみんなそれぞれお互いに関係やって生きてるんだっていうこと
そういう人々に良く見えてくるし
疲れているんだから それからどこかにも横になって寝るし
そういう人々はやっぱり洪水になったり
雨が降らなくて水がなくなったりしちゃうと
やっぱりついてないんだというぐらいのところで終わっちゃうんですよ
その時でももっと心配が出てきて
大変だ どうしよう 家族に
子供たちにどうやって食べさせればいいんでしょうかとかね
だから怒り 憎しみ あの人が悪い
この人が悪いとかね こんなことやったってろくな収入がないんだとかね
そんなことは考えませんね
だから全部揃っている現代時代では
怒る原因は全部取り消しちゃったんです
それが残っているんです
だからいくらでも怒れます
そこはね やっぱりなんて言いますか
本能だからね まあ正しく怒るならば
例えば病気になったならば
ものすごく嫌な気分になるとかね
それがいくらか でも論理的なんですね
病気になったところでえらい気分が良くなったとか
もう冗談言い出したっていうことは
ちょこっともう立派な人でない限りはありえないんですね
こんな時に限ってなんで風邪引いたんでしょうかとかは
言ったっても やっぱり人がやりたいことがいっぱいあって
その時に限って風邪引いてしまったし
それで気分が悪くなっているしっていうのは
そういう怒りが出ているんですね
そこまではなんとなく論理的と言えば論理的なんです
それも不全ですけど 病気になった時は怒るんじゃないんですよ
病気になったらもうなおさら明るくにならなくちゃいけないんですよ
病気を早く治したければ
病気を気にしないで 全然気にしないで処理をする
気にしないっていうか
病気を放ってまあ放っておくことじゃないんです
あまりそこは一応真剣に気にをしないで
まあそれなりに処理をするとすぐ早くなります
けど やっぱりそれは人間やらないんですね
それはやりにくい だから私は言って言いたがっているのは
貪瞋痴っていうのは基本的にあるんだから
不全思考っていうのはしやすいんです
慣れたもんだからね この慣れたもんだから
なんとなく気分よくやっちゃいますね
気分よくはなりませんよ
あの刺激があるんですね
それも苦しみの刺激なんです
怒って別に幸福を感じてるわけじゃないでしょうに
嫌な刺激を感じている
ああ 嫌だ この人々はと
それが喜んでいるんです
だから現代世界はね まあなんかもう一般人
社会評価論やったり 人々人々はかなり誘惑に溢れている
豊かで溢れている我々の世界で
あれは嘘です もうもともと頭が悪いんだからね
知識人になっちゃうし
まあそれはあんまりもう関係ないんで
けどまあよく客観的に見るとすごい怒り方なんですね
社会全体的に だからこんなに精神的に病気な人々が何で出るんですかね
何かあったんですかね？何もないでしょうね
ありえないんです 欲でダメになったというならば
まあやっぱり気持ちわかりますよと
人間っていうのはどうせ欲ですからと言えますけど
まあ全体的にすごい怒りになっていて
これはもうなおさら異常
異変ですね まあもともと貪瞋痴だから
我々にはまあ欲張りやすいし
怒りやすいし だからやってしまう
あの嫌な刺激のために
で 次に無智ってもありますね
無智の思考 無智っていうのはデータ処理を正しくしないっていうことですね
これも現代社会はすごく無智に陥りやすいんですね
だからどうでもいい 何の役にも立たん
もう概念 知識 知識っていうのはいくらでも増えますから
シャボン玉 泡みたいなもんですよ
吹けば吹くほど泡が出るんです
だからたくさん泡が立ったんだからどうってことないでしょう
同じあの水の量でいくらでも泡が作れますよ
だから子供二人が石鹸水を持ってきてね
同じ入れ物に似てる入れ物に入れて
じゃあ泡シャボン玉を作りましょうと
一人の子は大量に作ったら
一人の子とはちょこっと作ったり
別に大して意味がないでしょうに
内容的には同じですから
だから概念 考え方 思考っていうのはいくらでも膨らますことはできますよ
だから現代になってくると
この知恵というものは新しい知識
新しいもの いまだかつて知らなかったものが出たっていうことはほとんどないんです
その代わりに喋るは喋るは文章を書くは書くは
情報というものがいっぱいあれこれとあるわ
まあちょっとしたことにでも専門冊子まで出ますからね
あのゴルフというもの
どれぐらい専門冊子あると思いますかね
あれほど必要ですかね
それで微妙に分析したり
スイングの高さとか角度とかスピードとか
グリーンのなんだかかんだらことか
なんであの草一つ一つ計算して高さ計算して出してくれないんですかね
そこまで頭がないでしょうね
だったらあのグリーンだったら
まあこちらこれこれぐらいの草がありますから
まあ前の日は草刈りしてたんだから
今これぐらい伸びてますので
あのボールの摩擦これぐらいになりますから
この草にぶつけると もう何ミリ
これぐらい右に曲がりますよとか計算してくれればいいでしょうに
次の草の葉っぱにぶつけたら
また何ミリ これぐらいこちらに曲がります
それからこちらに曲がる
それ総合的に言えばこういう風になりますから
こういう角度でこういう風に打った方がいいんだよとかね
だから ただ単に遊びで球をなんとか打って打って穴に落とすだけのことですよ
それがもうやることないアホな人々には楽しいことなんですよ
人間っていうのは時間ないんだから
あの寿命っていうのは一本しかないです
よく覚えておくと 時間っていうのは一元ですよ
ライニアですよ 時間二つ同時に流れるということはないんです
[背景音楽]だから五分無駄にしたら
これは永久的にその五分無駄取り返しできない
だから時間で考えれば
五分無駄にしたらもう永久的にその無駄は無駄で残るんです
リセットしてまた五分
じゃあ五分あげますとということはあり得ません
だからお釈迦様はもう一番気を付けるべきとこに時間であると
これが無駄にするんじゃないよと
例えば半年間遊んだとすると
勉強研究しないでレポート出すところになってきたら
研究していないと それで指導者たちが「あ
わかった もうまあ君はまあ親切に
じゃああと半年間あげますよ」と
半年間もらったんですかね
もらってないです その人は一年目食っちゃったでしょうに
その人の寿命からは一年は消されたんですよ
これでものすごい大変なことなんです
そういうわけで 人間っていうのは体を動かすならば有効に動かすべきなんですよ
時間はものすごい大事にするべきなんです
時間はいくらもありっていうのはありえないんです
だから時間だけだったらもう無限になりますけど
時間は一人で成り立ちませんね
変化している我々物質とある時だけ時間が成り立つんだからね
そういうことで空観という状況の中では時間は成り立ちません
で 我々にはもう肉体を持って心を持って生きているんだから
心も物ですから 物ではなくて心も現象ですから
やっぱり時間 心さえも時間のあの一本の上で回転していますよ
だから手を挙げようと思ったら時間かかります
喋りながら手を挙げる時間と喋らないで手を挙げる時間
計算すれば喋らないで手を挙げる時は早いんです
時間は一本です だから人間持っている時計ではそこは計算できませんよ
時間というのは光の速度で計算で速度は計算できるような
素粒子のスピードを計算できるような時計でなければ駄目なんです
いわゆる一秒の一万分の1も数えられるぐらい
一秒も一万分単位でチェックしてくれる時計だったらよくわかります
喋りながら手を上げる
喋らないで手を上げると
そこで考えながら手を上げると
何も考えないで手を上げると
どちらの方が早いかと
差が見えます だから仏教はそれはものすごくよくよく研究しているところですよ
もう考える時は考えるんであって
身体は停止するんです
動かないんです そこで考えて
それから手を上げなくちゃということが出てきて
意識がそこで心がエネルギーを作るんです
作ったエネルギーが体に物体に伝わって
ちょっと上げると だからそうやって極力超スローモーションで物のことを考えると
この働きは見えます しかし
我々は何のことなく考えながら
そういうふうに手を上げたりする
同じことです 考えないでも同じ時間やと
それはもう我々の目で感じる
我々の時計で同じやと感じるだけで
で いろんなことを考えて手を挙げちゃうと時間かかりますよ
それで時間というのはそういうことで一本しかない
考えたってもある時間取ってしまう
ご飯食べる時もある時間取ってしまう
だから仏教の修行っていうのは
そのいつでも無駄を省いてみるんです
食べる時は他の一切思考を止めてみるんです
時間は 1本で一元であるということは
しっかり知った上で生きてみるんです
そこで真理に出会います
これ平行線で もう複雑なことに人間にできるんだという
あの嘘の概念がありまして
だから嘘だからそこは簡単に認めますし
だから嘘を言ったら人を認めるということは当たり前です
本当のことを言っちゃうと判断反対する
それって別に嫌味言う必要ないんですよ
そんなそれが人間の 何と言いますか
それも人間の本来の能力なんです
頭が無知無明だから嘘は正しく映るんです
だからもう単なる誰かさんがね
やっぱり脳が同時に平行線でいっぱいプロセッシング見たり聞こえたり
考えたり もう見ながら聞こえ
テレビ見ながら音楽も聞きながら
世の中のことを宿題のことを考えてたんだよとかね
やっぱり脳ってすごいですねとかね
同時に 10個 20個ぐらい仕事できるんだよと
極めて無知な人々なんで能力ないんです
そういう人々は それで
じゃあ私もそうやってもうできるようにしなくちゃいけないんだとかね
頑張っちゃうんです だからそこは嘘だから
みんなそこは真実っていう風にしてしまうんです
時間は 1本で 1次元やと言っちゃうと
そんなこと ありえないんだと
私にはできますよと考えながら
他のことを 私には人と喋りながら運転できますよというふうに思っちゃうんです
だから超スローモーションのスピードで見てみると
やっぱり喋る時は何もやってない
喋りながら運転できますよ
別に車自分で行ってるんだから
そこで調子を見てちょこっとそこでちょこっと調整すればいいんだからね
それからやることやることないんだから喋りますよ
では 険しい道を運転してみてください
信号もなくて 向こうから誰が来るかとわからない
すごい厳しい道なんかはガチャガチャガチャガチャ喋りながら喋ったら
その時何のことなく口止めますからね
カーブを通ったりしたりする時は
あるいは他の道路でぶつかったり
そこのもう田舎の農道みたいな道路ありますからね
その時から全然喋ってないんです
それで前に立ったところでそうですね
そういえばとまた始まるんです
もう車運転には心が入れなくなっちゃったんです
同時にできません 同時にできないっていうことを発見した人には能力あるんですよ
一つ一つやってやって
次のことに飛ぶんですからね
はい それは別に今日の説法には関係ないんですけど
言いたかったのは このまあゴルフの話から脱線しましたけどね
まあもう愚か者も時間無駄にしたければ
まあそこで球を打って穴に落としてもいいんですけど
それ自体も無駄な行為で何の役にも立ちませんですけど
まあそれでも人間にとっては楽しいことなんですね
それにもう百冊ぐらい冊子を読んでやると
どこに楽しみがあるんですかね
厳しい時間スケジュール作って
訓練場に行って  1 日 2時間
3時間訓練までして そこでスポーツですかね
それで会社で仕事をして
もう何か見栄張らなくちゃいけないんだから
もうだから私はゴルフやってますよと言わなきゃもう立場が
そのために行くでしょうね
趣味は？趣味は何か だから私は何かにアンケートを趣味は？って言ったら自慢げに無しと書きますけど
で 普通世界ではね やっぱりたくさんなった方が
いいと思ってますけど
だから私は人のもう趣味はあれこれ書いて読みますけど
全部同じリストなんです
ジョギングとかゴルフとか
まあ音楽で なんだらかんだら本を読むとかね
で 山登りとかね 結局はリストは決まってますからね
だから誰かの あの ちょっと書き方上手な人のホビーのリストをコピーして
あのコピー＆ペーストで
それはいいっていうことで
別にもう何か知ってても何も知らんだからね
まあだから我々の思考の恐ろしさ説明したかったんですよ
ゴルフというのは本来は楽しいはずなんです
もっと本来的ね 明らかにくだらないこと
時間の無駄 もっと何か有効的に時間使っちゃえばいいんだけど
まあしょうがなく時間を無駄に使っちゃいましょうということで遊びにゴルフに行く
そこまでもう悪口は言えません
それから人間が概念増やすんですよ
最初に打つあれにドライバー何て言いますか
あ？ドライバー それはなんだらかんだらカーボンでなくてあかんとかね
これ真ん中こんな角度でこういう風になければあかんとかね
で計算 やっぱり原っぱで球を球をね
穴に落とすこと 私は一本のドライバーでやった方がもっとスポーツ的じゃないかなと思いますけど
そこでなんでたくさんクラブを使うんですかね
その場にその場に合わせて上手に打てるクラブでしょ？何とかのアイアンとかね
最後にパターとかね ということは
いかに早く落としたいですだったら短くすればね
十メートルで 四百ヤードにしてもう四十分ぐらいクラブ使うと
だから概念増えて増えて
あのスポーツがどんどん苦しくなっちゃうだけ
それで間違ったアイアン
あれ取ってみてください
最悪ですよ 立場がないんです
私はグリーンの上ででもドライバーで打てると思いますよ
それで手のあれコントロールすれば
手の感触をね じゃあ打ってみてください
もう最悪 もう非難罵声いくらでも
だからそこですっごい極限な苦しみの世界を作ってるんです
それが無知ということなんです
無知の感情で 野球にしたってもう各プロの選手に選手に対して厳密にもう直直中であれ作らなくちゃいけないんですよね
バッターを だからこの世の中で我々のこの概念というものでいくらでも作られます
それに何か意味があると思ったりしたりして
そこはすっごくこの無知の衝動なんですよ
だから欲か怒りか無知
だから全体的に見ると
何やってもアホらしくてたまらんということになっちゃうんです
いつでも矛盾に出会うように
結果がゼロになるようにできています
いわゆる役に立たないということは
結果として 人間には趣味があった方がいいやと
いいでしょうね はい ではどんな趣味？じゃあゴルフにしましょうと
ではそれが結果がゼロになるようにしてやるぞと
一旦ゴルフ趣味にしたところで
ゴルフは趣味でなくなっちゃうんです
すごくストレスかかったりして
いっぱい冊子読まなくちゃいけないし
大変なことになる ネクタイにしたっても
知識だけはあるわあるわあるわ
そこで何も本当は何も理屈ない
この人にこのネクタイ合ってるかないかっていうことに
ある 私は一応やめました
ネクタイつけるのは まあだから私の世界にはネクタイっていうのはまるっきり関係存在もしない
だから私はその知識は全く要りませんし
そこで社会でずいぶんもうよく何でも知りという何人かと喧嘩になったところで
ネクタイのことでね これはこれこれこのこの子の理由で
この子の訳で 何でしゃべって
これはダメ これはこういうことでとかね
もうもうたっても見ていられません
私はいけないです これつけてみなさい
黙って 合わせてみなさいよ
って言ったらぴったし合うんですね
それだったら何やってるのかと
自分の頃でもみんなにこのある日もう本ぐらいネクタイ持って行ってね
色々男の男性たちに配った
普段は着けないんだからね
ある学校の先生でも やっぱりもう我々もそんなもう普通でもういいんだよと
言ったら 私はあなたね
一応社会の立場がある人でしょ
そっちいろんな人の結婚式あの祭りこの行くんだから
ちょこっともうかっこつけて行った方がいいんだよと
でもいいです 私には とこの人言うんですね
こんなつけたこともないし
合わないしと で 本人も頭で入れてみて
やっぱり合わないということで
私はそうですか では私があなたに３本あげますよと
いい加減に取って 合わなかったら行ってみなさいと
はい あげたんです 本人がつけてみたら
ぴったし合うんですね
ああ じゃあ使ってくださいと
だから何を言いたかったって
私は言いたかったかっていうと
何も知識もいらんということなんです
だから坊主ですごいいい加減に衣着ている私は
まあ結構青年たち 子供たちの場合はおしゃれ知らんだから結構やらせてあげますよ
これはダメよ これはダメとかね
別にそれにデザイナーは要りませんだけど
まあデザイナーっていうのは
日本ではね 特に現代世界ではすごい収入が入る仕事ですね
あれで何やってるんでしょうかね
やっぱり概念 概念 概念
概念だからやっぱり苦しいんだよ
やっぱりデザイナーの専門学校がなければね
人間頭が悪いんだからね
ダメですよ やっぱりデザイナーの専門学校に行って
ぐっちゃぐっちゃぐっちゃぐちゃ学んで
それでもあまり旗を立てることはできないし
卒業作品っていうのはなかなかできなくて
できなくて 苦労するんです
音楽のためにどれほど苦労しているのかというと
それでアフリカにいる黒人たちが森の中でなんとかもういい加減なんとか歌っちゃうと
これが世界的に素晴らしい新しい歌だと広げるんだから
情けないと なんで人間感じないんで
そういうことは ベートーベンやらモーツァルトやら
もう面白くもないのにそればっかりやってて
じゃあ何か書き作りなさいと言っちゃうとできないんだからね
それであの黒人の方々はね
森で動物を追っかけながら
もう獲物取ったら そこで火をたい所の周りに回って囲まって
別に言語もろくにないし
もう歌詞作りとかもほとんどないし
なんとか音を出して歌ってますよ
それでそこをじゃあこれがすごいやってくれて
結局はそういう音楽なんですよ
広げるの 何もいらん だからそこは知識で概念で分析しようとする
日本でも昔の人々はどんな学校もなく歌っていたんですけどね
田んぼで それで日本民謡という妄想世界に入っちゃうと
妄想ではなくて無知の世界に入ると
もう大学で学んだっても学びきれないんです
[背景音楽]日本民謡文化と
これはどんな風に音を作るのか
どういう風に楽譜を書ければよろしいかとかね
大変なことになるんです
昔のおばあさんは何のことなく歌っていたもの
その人々はその時思い浮かんだ単語を入れただけです
やれんそうれんとか何の意味もないでしょうに
でもすごいきれいでしょう
何のことなく人が歌っていると
もう一人が割り込んで何か言う
昔は それは今ちゃんと決めて一人が準備しているので割り込む
特に日本の民謡では割り込まなくちゃあかんでしょ
今 何て言いますか 緊張しながらビクビクしながら待ってますね
相手が歌ってて ちゃんと適当に割り込まなくちゃあかんから
だからやっぱりプロと一歩と夫婦で歌っているみたいですね
その時はもう何のこと自然に割り込みますから
だから結局人が歌っていると
もう一人が参加する そこで割り込みになる
自然に割り込んだ人の声の質が違うし
高さ違うし で わざと割り込むんだから
別にちょこっと変わったものを貢献したりする
自然に起きたことはこれで音楽になったところで
もう 1年  2年かかりますね
それを分野を研究するために
それから結果もになる
そのように我々は文化開発と言いながら
人間の喜びを喜べないものまで開発して持っていくんです
喜べないところではなくて
クタクタ苦しめるところに持っていくんです
だから現代社会っていうのは
昔 社会よりものすごく苦しみの塊になっています
というわけで 怒り中心になるっていうのは普通だとは思いますよ
情報ありすぎになっちゃうと
本当は概念ありすぎですよ
中身ないんだから それで無知が開発させていくんですね
それで無知でやっていることだったら逆効果になるっていうことは当たり前
お釈迦様のジャータカ物語もあるでしょうしね
だから猿を飼っていた王様がね
もう猿はすごい信頼できちゃって
動物は人間を裏切りませんよと
本当です 裏切りません
動物は嘘も言わないでしょう
だって喋れませんだからね
そういうことで人間は嘘を言うわ
動物は嘘も言わない ある王様が猿のことを可愛くて可愛くて飼っていて
だから公園で遊びに行って昼寝する
で もうもう家来の人は信頼できんだからね
自分の刀をね 王様が使うこの象徴の刀をね
これは何よりも切れるんです
それより一流のものは作りませんだからね
あの技術屋さんにしたっても
王様に作る刀よりは で
猿にあげて 猿もまあわかって
じゃあ守ってやろうではないかと
王様は守ってるんです
それで王様の額のところで
もうハエが来て もうプンプンと止まったりするんです
猿は掃除機だからこれ気に入らん
もう 自分のことをもう子供のように可愛がっている王様でしょうし
だから猿にとって王様というかということもないんだからね
自分飼ってる人が寝ている時
なんだこのこの野郎 このハエが邪魔するのかと
じゃあもう 2つにこうやって切ってやるぞと言って切っちゃったんだよ
ハエは 同時に王様の首も出て行って飛びましたけど
だからそのエピソードは使っているのは無知ということの恐ろしさ
無知に指導されると 無知がリーダーシップ取ると
結果が逆 期待した結果の反対になるんです
だから現代社会は知恵じゃないんですよ
理性じゃないんです リーダーシップっていうのは無知なんです
無知になったのは勉強していないんだからじゃないんです
ただ概念いっぱい シャボン玉いっぱいありすぎちゃって
それだけのことで 中身はない
だからゴルフの例出したんです
ただ概念だけ増えて増えていく
人間 特に一番恐ろしいのはこの女性のお化粧の世界なんですよ
で 私は何でも調べますけど
それだけはもう調べようとはしてないんです
情報はいくらでもあります
テレビつけちゃうと 大体二十分
十時間テレビつけちゃうと
大体八時間はお化粧のものですからね
だから こんなちっちゃな顔に塗るものについて見てみると
どれぐらい種類があるのかと
塗る順番とか だから唇の色ってどれぐらい種類ありますかね
唇の色って だから考えてください
それは服と自分の持ち
肌の色と着る服と それから履く
あの履き物 足に履くものは
あれ日本いろんなものを履いてますからね
何て言えばいいでしょうかね
いろんな種類の靴を履いたりするでしょうね
それにやっぱり靴の色に唇が合わないとダメですよ
だからそう考えてみると
いかに大変難しいかということなんですよ
だから概念はいくらでも増やせますよ
髪の色とネックレスと
それから服 そこを全部合わせて総合的に見て
じゃあ唇はこの色にならなくちゃいけないという
だからもう大体まあまあ
いくら何でも四十種類ぐらいはあるとは思いますけど
中で色を選ぶ だからそれで終わりませんよ
プロがその色を使わないんです
合わせるんです その中でも
だからそこ分かりますね
いかに苦しい世界作ったかと
ただ単に女性がちょっとおしゃれ好きで美しく見せるだけ
それだったら唇塗るの楽しくてたまらないはずなんですよ
あ これ あ これで可愛い
あ これでかっこいいとかね
でもどうでしたこれでは？とかね
聞いて 本当はものすごくふざけて楽しむはずのことでしたけどね
そうじゃない ものすごい真剣にプロのところに行って
メイクアップアーティストのところに行って
これ二 三時間かけてやってもらわなくちゃいけないことになるんです
だから無知に指導されると
すごいものすごく楽しく楽しいはずでした
おしゃれがいきなり地獄の結果出してくれるのです
だからどんな分野も同じなんです
初めは人間が楽しむではないかと
欲の正体で始まりますよ
だからそこまでいいんですよ
欲だから 楽しいんですよ
それからもう概念作って無知に
はい 先生お願いしますと
無知にお願いする 自分持ってる感情の中で
それで無知な先生は見事に出してくれる
やってくれます 全て極限に苦しい結果に出してやるぞと
そういうわけで我々にはもう楽しみがないんです
ブランドの服着ても楽しみだけはないようになってます
お化粧しても楽しみだけは得られない風になってます
金を儲けても それからそれ金でもって幸福になる
それだけはないようにと
俗世間ではそういう風になってますよ
そういうそういう面白い世界ですよ
だから怒り中心になるのはもうそういう必然的な結果になってます
なんでそんなに怒っているのかと
面白いですよ ちょっとああ上手ですねと言ったら
それにも怒るんです 褒めても怒る
褒めないとまた怒る 間違ってるところは
これはちょこっと違います
それにも怒る だからそんな風な
この何かどういう社会でしょうかね
人間作ってる社会っていうのは
この人間の思考の世界っていうのは
まあまあそんなところだと思いますけどね
一応悪っていうのはやりやすい
そういうわけで 他知りませんだからね
善って何なの？知ったことでもないんだから
一応でもそういう概念さえも頭の中にないんです
人間がこの悪に対立して善という概念あります
それはただの妄想概念です
善は知らないんです 悪知ってるんだからそちらの反という感じで
反説として善という概念は口先では使ってますけど
だから人間は悪に対する善だと思ってるものも形変わった悪だけに終わっちゃうんです
形を変えた別な悪 善にもならないんです
調べてください 社会状況は
みんなすごいいいことするんだぞと思っても
形変えた別な悪なんです
やってるの 知らないんです
はい だからといってこの法則は法則
問題はそういうことなんですよ
この科学法則というのは
もう人間個人の好みは関係はまるっきりない
だから厳密に数学の答えみたいな感じで
法則っていうのはしっかり動くんですよ
なんでそれ無視するのかと
それは無視してはいけません
物理法則ぐらいは知ってるでしょうに
物理は自分の好みで変わらないでしょうに
だから火を触りたいんだと
しかし火傷はしたくないんだと
それは成り立ちませんね
火を触ると火傷するっていうことはもう決まりで
法則であって 火傷しないで火を触る方法ないのか探すことも意味がないんです
ですから 法則っていうのは確実に原因に結果が出るということで
大げさなものでもないんです
行為に結果がある 結果がないはずがない
なぜなら全て無常だから
どうせ流れなくちゃいけないんです
ものは止まりませんから
時間の上だから全て成り立っているのは
だから時間と一緒に動かなくちゃいけないんです
だからものは止まりません
一定しません 次 別な形を取らなくちゃいけないんです
それが法則っていうこと
だから行為に結果がっていうのは当たり前のことで
もう話にならない それはもう話して説明する必要もないんです
こちらが花があるとしたっても
そんなあると言ったってもありえないんですよ
なぜならば もうあると言ったとも時間とって立ってるんだからね
その今あると言った花が次の時間で変わらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからずっと時間と一緒に変わっていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
言葉で今花がありますよと言ったっても
花にはそんなのんびりある状態でいる余裕がないんです
花があるんだって言っても
もう 1 秒の 1000分の1も経ってますからね
だから別な時間でいるんだから
別な花にならないと だからそう言って変わるんだから
だから 1 秒の前の花が原因になって
今の 1 秒の花があるんです
言語で花といっても だからその 1 秒過ぎ去ると
その 1 秒の原因によって
次の 1 秒の花がそこで成り立っています
それで秒単位で見ると
全然変わってないでしょうと思ったっても
じっと見ていてください
秒が増えると見事に変わっているんです
だから我々に変わったと目で見えるのは
もう大体 1週間経ってからなんですね
花があります ある 来週やっぱり花が枯れてますねと
いつ枯れたんですかね
何時何分何秒で  1週間で花が枯れると言ったっても
夕の場合は６日になっても枯れるはずがないでしょうに
それで６日経って ちょうど12時ピンと
もう枯れちゃって それはありえないでしょうに
私はこの間 成人式終わっちゃったっけ？今年の
だから何か私の部屋に来の間泊まっていた子は何か成人式に行くんだと京都の方でということだから
要するに冗談で思ったのは
だから 20歳で酒飲んでメインですね
それであのー 誕生日のね
前にいっぱいいろんな人を呼んでもらって
警察官もね 呼んでもらって
酒いっぱい用意しておいて
ちょうど11時59分
あって 58秒 9秒 はい 10
時飛んだ はい それで酒の警察にはもうどうすることもたった 1 秒変わっただけで
未成年酒飲むなよと できないでしょ？ 1 秒前で飲んだらあんた未成年だよと
だから 1 秒で未成年が成年になります
1 秒の差で 人間の世界はそんな世界なんですよ
そうなるんですかね  [ silence]だから事実はそれとはまるっきり違うんです
あって これって世界で言ってることはいい加減って当たり前でしょうに
二十歳にならなかったら酒とタバコはダメですよと
これは一秒で決めます
最低本人の誕生日と生まれた時間
みんなこの時間から二十歳だよと計算すると
ちょこっと待ちでしょうね
それはやってないんですよ
それだったら一人一人違うでしょ？二十歳になる一秒は
そういうわけで 花が枯れるために一週間っていうのは成り立ちません
今の一秒の花が原因で
次の一秒の花が成り立つ
それで説明はできるということだから
物は止まらない 心も止まらない
すべて流れていく 流れるんだから
止まらないで変わるんだから
因果法則っていうのは絶対的で唯一の法則になるんです
存在に対して それ以外全部いい加減なうわごと
知識人とは言わない もう概念
概念 人間の シャボン玉人間のいうのはただうわごとであって
概念はシャボン玉作る事と同じですからね
いくらでも作れると ですから
知識で因果法則ということはもう絶対的法則になるんであって
これは言っても言わなくてももうそんなもんです
法則です だから行為には結果がある
だからそこと我々の生き方と見ると
我々はとんでもない危険な生き方をして
一時的な気持ちで 頓珍致の気持ちで生きていたっても
結果が出る 出るのは当たり前
もうどうにもならん それは
次に次にどんな結果になるかということは
誰にもどうすることもできません
物は変化する どうしましょう
どうしましょう どうもできません
部屋に置いた食べ物はもう悪くなるかもしれない
じゃあ冷蔵庫に入れておきましょうと
冷蔵庫に入れたんだからって変化止まる
止まりませんよ 冷蔵庫に入れたら原因変わったんだから
別な変化プロセスになるだけ
部屋に置いておるとまた条件変わってますから
別な変化プロセスに入るだけ
しかし 同じスピードで変化はしていく
そういうわけで 我々は頓珍致の衝動であらゆる悪行を悪業したり
感情の刺激で生きてあっても
適切に結果が出ることは誰にもどうすることもできないんですよと
ことは繰り返しな口を言わないんです
[ページをめくる音]